so as we continue our series about the
various Robins or the most prominent
robins that have played this character
over the course of that man's continuity
what we're going to be doing here is
we're going to be picking up with Tim
Drake and Tim Drake is arguably the most
popular Robin that has existed in the
Batman continuity second only to maybe
Dick Grayson here
now Tim Drake in truth I guess first
appeared in Batman issue number 436 but
I don't really consider this the first
real comic book appearance of Tim Drake
because in truth he only appears on one
panel he's being held by his father
while he's traveling through Haley
circus with his mother and this is
really just kind of a flashback scene
all this really does is tell us that Tim
Drake was at Haley's circus and the
reason why I'd say this is probably a
probably important here is because in
Batman issue number 441 this is when Tim
Drake first appears now Tim Peake was
created by Marv Wolfman and Pat
Broderick and the reason why he appeared
as part of a five part series called a
lonely place of dying
now what DC did is when they look back
at the idea of Dick Grayson and what it
was it made Dick Grayson popular and
they compared and to Jason Todd and they
asked why was Jason Todd so unpopular I
believe they came to the realization
here that ultimately because Jason Todd
was introduced as a carbon copy of Dick
Grayson fans didn't like this fans
looked as though DC was basically
rehashing the same thing and DC was
trying to give them what they'd already
had and so DC went back to the drawing
board here and so the introduction of
Tim Garrett Emma Drake into into Batman
comics is done in an extremely
interesting way what we find is that Tim
Drake just shows up at the Wayne Manor
one day he said we just appears of
course he speaks with Alfred and we also
find that Alfred is being accompanied by
Dick Grayson then what Tim Drake
basically says is that he knows exactly
what the real identities of Batman and
Nightwing are now initially they're a
little skeptical here but once he tells
them he knows their identities are Bruce
Wayne and Dick Grayson respectively then
they immediately catch the attention or
I guess he immediately has the attention
of both Alfred and and Dick Grayson
and so what Tim Drake does is he takes
us on this kind of explanation here he
takes us on this kind of history of his
life up to that point what we learn is
that when when Tim Drake was a child
that he had been taken to Hayley Circus
by his mother and his father but that he
had been taken to Hayley's circus on the
same day that dick Grayson's parents had
died and so what we saw was that when
Tim Drake was watching this entire event
unfold that when dick races parents had
been killed that Batman
arrived and Tim Drake had become I guess
aware of the fact that Batman was
basically a superhero because again for
Tim Drake Batman was more of a myth he's
similar he was someone that that 10
Drake had never really seen before and
so the question is is Batman really who
he claims to be or is it something else
and so what happens is that as time
progresses Tim Drake develops this sort
of affinity for Batman and Robin none of
the Simpson it's an obsession but in the
sense that is really more of a curious
thing it's a way for him to fill his
time and the reason why is because his
parents are very successful businessman
or a businessman and a businesswoman so
as a result they travel the world
constantly and they usually leave Tim
Drake by himself but at the same time
their marriage is kind of on the rocks
they're trying to fix this I guess while
all this is going on and so what happens
is at end Drake witnesses Batman and
Robin fighting together and he sees
Robin or he sees Dick Grayson perform a
move that he had seen Dick Grayson
perform when he was operating at Haley
circus and putting those two things
together Tim Drake comes to the
realization that Robin is Dick Grayson
from there what we found was that Tim
Drake continued on this path of
reasoning and came to the realization
that if Bruce Wayne had adopted Dick
Grayson as his Ward and Dick Grayson as
Robin was fighting alongside Batman then
it stood to reason that Bruce Wayne is
Batman and this was so well received by
fans I can't even begin to tell you guys
it was unbelievable because what fans
were getting now as they were getting
what they felt should have been the
second Robin they're getting what they
felt should have been the character that
would step into the role of Robin after
Dick Grayson it was so well received
that again
to this day a lot of people say that Tim
Drake was the best version of Robin they
had ever seen now the DC played this
very very carefully DC actually played
it very intelligently going forward with
Robin in DC Comics what we found was
that it wasn't as though he had appeared
in issue number 441 and then issue
number four for 442 he was Robin instead
what we found was that over the course
of this series that Bruce Wayne was
actually reluctant he didn't want to
take on another partner he didn't want
to have somebody fulfill this role and
then die in the same fashion that Jason
Todd did and so as a result what we
found was that
the end of issue number 442 that Bruce
Wayne reluctantly accepts Tim Tim Drake
on as his partner but tells Tim Drake
that he's going to be doing things
differently this time and instead he's
going to put him through a very long
drawn-out process he's going to ensure
that he can withstand the physical and
psychological effects of what it means
to fight alongside Batman and so what we
find over the subsequent issues leading
up to a 1993 and the nightfall story arc
is that Tim Drake plays this character
initially as Robin who is really more of
an aid more of an assistant to Batman
rather than being out in the field
he helps Batman look over things inside
the Batcave he helps him by gathering
information and giving him that
information proper but one of the other
really cool concepts too when it came to
Tim Drake was that not a whole lot was
known about his parents all we really
knew at least all the DC would give us
was that Tim Drake was given the
explanation that his parents were
travelling now this was really kind of a
cool thing because it left readers I
guess to their imaginations to really
try to figure out what was going on but
in Detective Comics issue number 621
what they did is they revealed in this
storyline that dhikr I'm sorry that Tom
Drake's parents had been kidnapped and
they were being held captive by some
kind of voodoo priest and that as they
had been released in order for them to
basically continue surviving they
immediately ran and drank this sort of
holy water but almost immediately after
consuming the holy water Tim Drake's
mother dies and his father falls into a
coma and is eventually paralyzed but
what this did is it basically gave
readers a way to look at Tim Drake in
the same eyes ask Batman with which in
truth I would go as far as to say may
not necessarily have been the best
decision because I think what really
separated Tim Drake was the fact that
his parents were alive he had no kind of
no beef with with regards to any but he
didn't have this sort of inherent drive
to pursue criminals his argument was
simply that Batman needed a Robin in the
same way that Gotham needed Batman that
was his logic that's why he did what he
did that's why he pursued Batman but
what we would find is that all of this
would start to change all of this would
start to evolve when we saw a DC
launching the nightfall story arc in
1993 which would take Batman out of the
limelight after his back was broken by
Bane
it would give the opportunity for Tim
Drake it would give the opportunity for
Dick Grayson to step into the role to
basically have their moment to shine but
what we also saw here is that with no
real Bruce Wayne and the role and with
Dick Grayson playing the character of
Batman
somebody had to continue the role of
Robin then this is where Tim Drake
continued to flourish because now the
focus wasn't so much on Batman anymore
it was now on Tim Drake what can Tim
Drake could do can Tim Drake really
flourish as a as a sidekick as a
superhero in and of himself and this is
something that we saw him do over the
course of the next five years four or
five years between 1993 and 1998 we saw
Tim Drake grow and expand in ways that
we had never really seen with any of the
other Robins and in the Batman
continuity and in 1998 what we saw was
that DC had intended to launch Young
Justice now the initial idea here was
that Teen Titans the second volume was
going to come back and it was going to
be a way to bring Tim Drake into the
fold but the DC editors really just
didn't want to see this happen they
didn't want to see Tim Drake leaving or
even not taking part in the Teen Titans
as well as Batman because what they were
afraid is it would take away from Batman
sales especially with Bruce Wayne not
being in the fold at the moment and so
what we found was that with Young
Justice this was a way for DC to
incorporate this new generation of
teenage superheroes which had been
spawned due to the success of Tim Drake
and we saw them basically crossing over
and then coming together as a single
team and this lasted for quite some time
now going into Teen Titans vol 3 this is
when we saw a DC going back and taking
Tim Drake and putting them in the Teen
Titans now the team Titans team as a
whole was reformed with some of the
older members coming back but what we
also saw was that Superboy that Tim
Drake and others were becoming part of
the Teen Titans team they were helping
to build build this foundation once
again and DC fans loved this concept
they love this idea because for them
there was a way to get back into the
concept get back into the idea of
hanging out with Tim Drake of reading
Tim Drake stories of watching Tim Drake
grow watching him expand and step into
the role of becoming a much larger
character in the realm of DC Comics now
following this in 2009
we saw that that Tim Drake and
undertaken the mantle of Red Robin and
the reason why this was done was because
at this point in time we had Infinite
Crisis and the belief was that Batman
had simply been killed off when he was
and when in truth with the Infinite
Crisis story Batman Istanbul just been
lost in time and so as a result there
was no one to play the role of Batman so
we saw this role being fulfilled yet
again but ultimately we saw that Tim
Drake with his Red Robin persona was
going under the mantle of trying to find
out what happened to Batman traveling
the world going around meeting different
people and this again gave us a chance
to watch Red Robin grow to watch Tim
Drake grow into a much bigger character
until eventually we would find him
rebooted with the new 52 so with a new
52 like many of DC's characters DC came
back and they consolidated a lot of the
stuff that had to do with Tim Drake into
a very small and neat package now Tim
Drake does have a new 52 origin into a
Teen Titans issue number zero but he was
also featured in Secret Origins issue
number three and so what we're going to
be doing here is we're going to be using
secret origins because what this is
going to do is effectively give us the
Teen Titans number 0 origin but it's
also going to add a couple tidbits in
here a few things that weren't in the
the Teen Titans origin story and so
again what we find with Tim Drake is
that he is very well adept in using
various computer systems and so on but
much like his pre new 52 counterpart he
was able to deduce the identity of
Batman now the way in which he's able to
deduce the identity of Batman isn't
necessarily I guess as well given to us
as it is in the pre new 52 origins and
the reason for this is because DC is
really just kind of captive it is
capitalizing on the popularity of Tim
Drake and pretty much telling us that
things are still the same that in terms
of how it is that he decided her if I
guess figured out who Batman was that
it's all still pretty much the same that
much hasn't really changed at all and so
what we find is that he is basically
contacted by Batman what's Batman
realizes what it is that he's doing when
when Tim Drake reaches out and what
Batman says that he's initially
impressed over what it is that that Tim
Drake is able to do here that he was
able to deduce the identity of Batman
and what Tim Drake says is he wants to
become the new Robin he wants to
undertake the role
fighting as a sidekick for Batman but
much like the pre new 52 basis for the
relationship between Tim Drake and and
Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne initially says
no here because again this is very soon
after the death of Jason Todd and so as
a result what Tim Drake does is he goes
to an ATM machine and he hacks this ATM
machine and he ends up transferring
millions of dollars from I guess from
Oswald Cobblepot or the Penguins bank
account to some sort of unnamed charity
and as a result the the penguin sends
assassins after Tim Drake and then
Batman arrives to rescue Tim Drake in
order to save him and his family from
being killed and so as a result what
happens here is Tim Drake's parents go
into witness protection and Tim Drake
himself is adopted by Batman this is
when things get really interesting here
because unlike what we saw with the pre
new 52 whereby Tim Drake had played the
role of Robin for quite some time before
adopting the mantle of Red Robin what
happens here is he doesn't want to fall
into the same footsteps he doesn't want
to walk the path it's already been
walked and so instead of undergoing the
mantle of calling himself Robin instead
he simply just calls himself Red Robin
and so what this does is this leads us
into the entire new 52 run of Tim Drake
this leads us into him fighting
alongside the Teen Titans this leads him
into the current events dealing with
Damian Wayne and so on and so forth but
again what we're going to do is go ahead
and in this video here because I don't
want to get too far into this otherwise
like the other videos that we have we
may end up running into some of the
Batman lore and I'm really kind of
spoiling the events as they unfold with
the Batman comics getting into endgame
but that being said we're gonna go and
bring this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys on it
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explain and talk to me
directly
you